[Music]
i was like everyone else initially
extremely turned off to square enix
doing a guardians of the galaxy game
after the smoldering dumpster fire
failure that was avengers and i was one
of the people who initially went pretty
easy on avengers because it had stuff i
liked
i enjoyed the chemistry and banter
between the characters the tighter focus
on the linear levels but everything else
in the realm of the live service
portions of the game was a boring
disinteresting slog because they didn't
even know how to make a live service
game properly the whole point was to
incentivize you to want to pay money and
play the game a ton and it failed doing
both of those so i looked at guardians
and was like you i want another one of
those games
i wasn't even planning to buy it but my
good buddy james portis over at on
comics ground had a code for a review
copy and asked me to do a more condensed
review of the game over on his site
thank him for hooking me up by checking
out his site and giving him a follow
well i sure do like getting things for
free because i'm not made out of money
and i decided to take him up on his
offer and give it a try
after properly playing it i can
confidently say
this is the exact game i think avengers
should have been if i had known this was
the final result i would have paid for
it because this game is a triumph built
on all of avengers numerous failings
guardians of the galaxy is everything
avengers failed to be
but before we get to more of that this
video is sponsored by exeter the world's
largest smart wallet brand whose goal is
to design innovative solutions to the
way you carry items extra was kind
enough to ship me one of their awesome
smart wallets so i can unbox it and
check it out for you i'm struck by just
how thin it is compared to other wallets
it's the same size as a typical cell
phone but it still carries just as much
for your cards and cash in a very
durable high quality leather casing it
has a handy button on it for extending
all of your cards without opening it
what makes it even more revolutionary is
this tracking card that hooks up to the
chipolo app on your phone
so this is one wallet you don't have to
worry about losing you can ring the card
from your phone to hear that pesky
wallet in your couch cushions and you
can ring your phone with this button on
the card if you ever lose that between
the seats at the movie theater extra
smart wallets are designed to protect
you from skimming and potential thieves
with their easy to use solutions for
always keeping track of your money try
out one of exer's smart wallets and
various other time-saving designs to
carry better using my special link in
the description now back to the video
your differences are your greatest
superpower one of my comments about what
the avengers game lacked was that the
characters didn't feel unique to play as
and this pulls a total 180 everyone does
something different and contributes
something different star-lord has
elemental blasts in his detective mode
visor gamora can climb higher than
anyone serve as an anchor point to boost
you up and cut down obstacles
drax can lift and move heavy objects
groots vines and tendrils can make
bridges or snare enemies rocket can
climb into small spaces and hack
machinery everyone actually has
something to do
unlike the avengers game where the main
gameplay loop was punching and then
doing a half-baked traversal mechanic to
get around
sure you had minor puzzles like captain
america's shield activating buttons but
those were only for moments where you
were forced to play as him and ninety
percent of time you're not in a level
linear enough to even have said puzzles
a few of those you could just as easily
do with any character's projectile too
there's a lot of nice downtime in
guardians between the actiony stuff of
just entering an area where i wasn't
sure how to progress and then having the
team figure it out for me while i sat
back and used my space cell phone to
catch up on chucky except i couldn't
hear it with all the friendly ribbing
and banter going on between these
spatially diverse schmucks talking over
my precious brad duraf cackling
says there's something down there
shut the hell up i was taken back by
just how much the team banters
this game is packed with dialogue the
team has a contextually appropriate
comment for everything from star-lord
[ __ ] off the main path to go explore
and look for unlockables fortresses
i know i'm just doing some exploring
maybe done enough of that already i'm
pretty sure exploring is code
it means he went the wrong way but is
too stubborn to admit it
in that case will's the greatest
explorer i ever met
shooting your gun randomly for no reason
did you see a monster no just trying to
stay ready to full conversations if you
picked the wrong guy to accomplish a
task
i don't know
rocket can you take care of those
branches you want me to blow it up that
shouldn't be our answer to everything
good thing we have a plant guy to take
care of a plant problem
he says plants aren't problems
drax think this is a sign from lady
hellbender we are clearly not wanted on
this planet
can you get us through here gamora
whatever it takes to find hellbender
to just
everyone chatting when you stand around
idling or taking too long to figure out
a puzzle
these guys practically never shut up and
that's incredibly impressive from a
technical standpoint because writing
recording and programming that amount of
dialogue is no easy feat i feel like
this game warrants multiple playthroughs
for that feature alone because it's so
easy to miss dialogue if you're running
through a normal pace at some point i
have to do a lazy star lord play through
where i take 40 percent longer to
accomplish anything just to see where
you exhaust the amount of conversations
i think this game has set a new bar for
just how much dialogue a game can have
because i don't think i've ever
encountered one with this much outside
of like a giant open world rpg game and
these conversations are witty funny and
informative about the lore and
characters too you get a sense that
these characters are buddies and know
each other pretty well because they
always have something to say to and
about one another or a story to tell
about past adventures or one of them
just has some interesting information
that only they know and can share with
the group and i really dig that you have
the option to jump in and influence the
conversation by picking sides in an
argument trying to cheer up the team
when they're down or just cracking bad
jokes to boost morale especially in
these first person segments where you're
just watching everyone have a
conversation from this lockdown camera
angle and you get to participate too i
don't know if this game necessarily made
me feel like star-lord but it sure made
me feel like i was there talking to
these guys and really getting to know
them there's even some influence from
the telltale style of games now
with little notes acknowledging how
characters react to your choices and
actions but you might be wondering is
this game a bit of a missed opportunity
with not being able to play as all 5
members a lot of people were really
disappointed that this game was not
multiplayer however i feel like
guardians manage to make it work you're
dealing out team commands so frequently
in battle upgrading every member of the
team and using their various skills for
puzzles so much that it almost feels
like you are playing as all of them
albeit a little indirectly
you get a good sense that you're the
leader and they follow your commands to
the letters so you have control of all
five characters at once it's like having
a team of four multicolored atreuses
with different weapons and skills and
god of war actually that makes me wonder
what it would be like to have a ninja
turtles game where you just play as
splinter as for star-lord's controls
himself i'm glad this isn't really a
hack and slash melee focused game like
avengers because the constant button
mashing in that felt really tedious this
one's more of a shooter with an emphasis
on run and gunning with your blasters
and dodging around enemies star-lord's
got a melee attack but it's not the best
which is what you have your team for you
hang back to shoot and guide everyone on
what to stab from distance or in the air
it feels like an extremely simplified
version of an rts game in that regard
and i think it worked pretty well it's
always nice using different combinations
of special attacks from your team to do
a lot of damage i did end up enjoying
this game's combat system quite a bit
and hey look at the skill trees for
character upgrades i don't need a manual
and a youtube guide to explain how to
navigate these god damn menus and
upgrade the characters to not be totally
worthless it's just a list
can this be the standard again can we
throw this away forever
like i seriously i i just don't want to
play games that have this anymore i'm so
sick of this
and i know that's a like a weird hot
take but [ __ ]
how do we go from this nonsense to just
having costumes you pick up off the
ground like a ps2 game that's so retro
and fun and i love it
but it also sickens me that this is no
longer the default way of doing this
you just
explore
and find it laying around
i haven't seen that since the x-men
origins wolverine game
37 units
yes we should go after finn fang foom
drax there are easier ways to get paid
like what about selling gamora's crap
you guys look stupid you got dozens of
costumes across all these characters
that are all unique none of them are
shitty eyesore recolors that have no
excuse to exist like a hot pink and
orange groot look i don't mind paying
for cosmetics in a game
if they're unique and look good
fortnite i know cringe i get it has all
these diverse costumes with special
crafting tools and emotes and parachutes
and the styles from them even changed
the model in most cases but the avengers
game is over here asking you to drop
twenty dollars for a purple iron man
like that's something people want or
care about when spider-man finally gets
added to avengers all of his admittedly
pretty cool skins will have stuff like
this thrown in because they can't help
themselves oh you got a werewolf captain
america that looks bad and ruins
cutscenes how quaint big ups to
guardians and spider-man for being the
gold standard all these character skins
are unlocked in the game for free
they're all different and look good
i really appreciate that they even say
what the costumes first appearance was
and who designed it
i i think the spider-man series could
take a cue from that
support comic book creators kids
lord knows the industry won't do it or
even necessarily credit them properly
when using their work in movies the
levels only allow for a limited amount
of exploration but there's still enough
to keep you sidetracked and grabbing
unlockable costumes and upgrades here
and there
plus these levels have a ton of variety
visually and how they play from a
floating graveyard of exploded starships
held together with space glue
to a lush forested planet with exotic
alien wildlife and heavy winds
to a grungy space city like nowhere to
an ice plant covered in ruins in the
trail of dead explorers killed by a
dragon
to a bunch of other crazy [ __ ] i'm
really happy that none of this game was
like
seven or eight maps of reused tree
assets to make dull forests of
indistinct robots this game isn't
perfect obviously as much as i enjoyed
it i played it early and saw a lot of
distracting bugs with certain character
models or ear piercing audio glitches
and i hope that'll all be patched
eventually
it might also not have helped that i
played it on ps4 because
uh donate to the patreon if you want me
to get a playstation 5 at some point in
the next five years and when the game's
working as intended it has all the
hallmarks of a lot of big budget aaa
games lately
that are becoming very tiresome tropes
every major blockbuster video game now
needs to really visibly break up the
pacing of combat with a room full of
interactable items that you're forced to
go investigate one by one at a slow ass
walking pace you have no choice but to
go look at all these different elements
of the set piece and listen to
characters comment on them
the level of gameplay here is so low
that it makes me wonder why they even
bother letting you pick it up yourself
if it's mandatory at least hide the
stuff a little so i have to find it or
something just like a little more
engagement
because at this point just make it a
long cut scene a lot of more expensive
games are trying so hard to be cinematic
lately that they railroad you into
scenes like this and it gets irritating
especially on your second playthrough
like yeah i heard all this before can i
please get back to fighting or swinging
around the city or stabbing zombies or
whatever and can we have a single aaa
game where there isn't a section of an
older dad player character watching over
a young girl that's either his
biological or surrogate daughter
every damn video game now is about being
a dad because all the game developers
are now in their 40s and have kids at
least god of war broke the mold by
having it be a boy that time i think
developers and writers are usually
afraid to have the kid character be a
boy because it's easier to find them way
more annoying
like the way everyone reacted to duck in
the walking dead game even though he
wasn't that bad you're the greatest
detective and i could be dick grayson
you're ward
that's robin i know who it is wow you
sure are dick grayson little buddy
because you're dead
what the [ __ ] actually that's a
relatively small part of guardians to
set up the plot early on but it's
it's getting a little old as a concept
how about at least a game where you're a
sad mom where are all the mom games you
got like resident evil 2 and that's it
give me a ripley and newt game
or hell give lara croft a teenage son if
you want to be different and still have
an npc for players to care about just
some variety please can't forget sidling
through narrow spaces to hide the
loading screens this game has the most
of those i think i've ever seen in one
place
and sometimes they're actually not very
easy to spot so you end up just getting
kinda lost for a little while i like
that this game didn't feel the need to
handcuff itself to the mcu version of
the guardians
sure the inspiration is absolutely
visible but there's a lot of really
obscure stuff here that really hasn't
even been mentioned in the mcu like
wendigo richard ryder dark hawk alpha
flight galactus and practically every
major character is from a random issue
of one book or another from the 80s
they had a huge toy box of stuff to use
from the comics and they grabbed a
handful i love the utilization of random
cosmic characters when was the last time
you heard someone talk about darkhawk in
a video game
darkhawk is faster than you
okay spoiler territory watch out and
more than a few of these obscure comic
references end up making for awesome
boss battles like the twins that are
invulnerable as long as they're close
together you have to play it smart and
separate them to do some damage
or this cool octopus thing that's all
one of those fights you know those it's
a one of those
and then you fight finn fang foom i
haven't fought him since 2006 what a
rush i guess i guess i should talk about
the story now so
guardians of the galaxy star's mullet
lord is the leader of a team of
intergalactic heroes for hire with some
questionable ethics but hearts of gold
on a mission to steal a rare animal from
a quarantined part of space to sell for
profit our heroes accidentally unleash a
powerful evil entity called the magus
that infects the galaxy with his mind
control promising to return their dead
loved ones if they give it universal
control but while the magus is building
its forces in secret the guardians are
caught committing their theft and have
to pay a seven thousand 000 fine but the
currency is space chuck e cheese tokens
this leads them on an adventure to both
save the galaxy and not get thrown in
jail by a space police officer that
star-lord used to date
who has a daughter that might be
star-lord's kid that he never knew about
but the magus takes control of nikki the
would-be star kid and uses her as a
conduit to spread its evil influence
everywhere
this means the guardians can't exactly
go in guns blazing against the enemy
since there's an instant child under all
that forcing them to some really crazy
alternatives to save the day the story
spends a lot of time really developing
the individual traumas of the team and
showing us how it's affected them this
version of the guardians is united by
being misfits but also by being subject
to great loss groot's home planet drax's
family peter's mother gamora's sister
and rocket's friends that were
experimented on when he was first
created the game gives us time to
confront and overcome each of the
guardians personal traumatic memories
either by talking about their feelings
being forced to overcome a fear to save
the team
or more direct methods of literally
having to kill their grief i really
enjoyed getting to know this version of
the team and the story structure of
guardians reminds me a lot of mass
effect like how you do loyalty missions
for each of your crew to really get in
their heads learn their backstories and
earn their trust this is also reflected
by the game having choices that subtly
influence the outcome of the story like
i said before i hate games where the
choice is a binary which flavor birthday
cake do you want and if you pick the red
frosting a school bus full of children
explodes and the entire cast of
characters stand in a circle shaming you
and throwing rocks at you because you're
a terrible person
the choices here only really affect the
difficulty of the final level by having
different characters from throughout the
story show up to help you allowing you
to one-shot enemies that would normally
be incredibly tough or skipping some
combat sections altogether i
accidentally got like a perfect run in
that regard and got everyone there by
the end of my playthrough the story
wouldn't have been a total bummer full
of characters scolding you if they
weren't there but it's nice to have them
there as backup this is like the exact
level of choices i like in games i want
more games like this that ultimately
have like about the same ending no
matter what i do so i don't get the
ending where the universe explodes
because i didn't look up a guide
why did i like mass effect so much again
oh that's right the story element that
worried me the most in the first
playthrough was the character of nicki
and the possibility of giving star-lord
an illegitimate character development
daughter like so many other comic book
characters recently you're an
irresponsible train wreck of a man
here's a 12 year old child to make you
get your act together because the
original ideas are dead but she isn't
your daughter she's not my daughter
she's a war orphan
but this game subverted that trope by
revealing that nikki is not his daughter
but just the thought of it gets him to
really care for her and take the mission
of saving her more seriously than
anything before i really like this more
compassionate and mature version of the
character and i felt really attached to
his arc of becoming more responsible
through the game while also learning to
let go of his grief
[Music]
there's some really gut-wrenching
moments in here that might be hard to
sit through for some people and i admire
that risk
[Applause]
[Music]
and
we're laughing that's
good
it's just it's perfect
this is us this is how we
park this is our quote parks anyways
we were not created to die this day
unless of course
devours us
[Laughter]
guardians is a wonderful story that's
touching fun exciting and full of heart
these characters are all [ __ ] but
they love each other and at the end of
the day they're just trying to do the
right thing in spite of all their
mistakes the characters have amazing
chemistry and the gameplay works in
service of their story instead of
against it
their differences is people are utilized
incredibly well in gameplay and everyone
feels like an individual you can get
really attached to
your differences
i wasn't a fan of most of the creative
choices the avengers game made but there
were elements of something great under
the surface
maybe it was meant to end up like this
and they changed it into a live service
game at the last minute but regardless
guardians is just everything i liked
about avengers without the huge parts
that i hated it's a full and fulfilling
experience that's technically impressive
full of great payoffs and gameplay
that's unique with a story that kept me
engaged and invested the whole way
through this is the comeback story of
the millennium
that being said i'm still not playing
this again until that dlc comes out
because you and
even then i don't i don't know man i
don't know
what kind of name is avengers
[Music]
[Music]
you